hey I'm Madison Beer and these are my
[Music]
places the place that does the best
brune order okay we're taking you to La
um and we're going to salts cure this
place has the best okay I'm trying to
also do the the person thing and then
wait Zoom no wait yes oh there we go got
it yes okay this place has the best
pancakes they have these they're called
oatmeal griddle cakes is what they call
them and you would think oatmeal
pancakes they're probably like healthier
versions they are not healthier versions
which is a good thing cuz they're just
like amazing and they're covered in like
brown sugar maple whatever and I love
this place it's delicious it's amazing
and they have great brunch and I
actually think they serve brunch really
late a lot of places in La well I don't
I think brunch cuts off at a certain
time but that bothers me because I want
breakfast all day what's your coffee
ordera I actually don't drink coffee I
know shocking Place prob would happily
stay forever I'm going to throw this
back to my summer camp that I grew up
going to because I loved summer camp so
much it was in brand Lake um which let's
see if it yes oh my goodness okay also
would happily die here this place this
is where my summer camp was which I
think this is the ground wait this is a
Baptist Church this is not the grounds
of my summer camp hold on a second we
could just go to my summer camp actually
I think oh my gosh let's go to my camp
oh my God I'm going to cry my eyes out
yes yes okay oh my gosh you guys okay I
used to water ski out of here
every morning okay oh my goodness yeah
so I would die here happily for sure
love a lake I love Lake Sports I love I
actually grew up water skiing as well so
I like love all that stuff so find me
here find My Dead Body here I'm just
kid
this is going to be if this comes up I'm
going to be shocked oh my goodness it
came up okay there is a Street in
Beverly Hills in Los Angeles called
Ferrari drive and there's an amazing
Lookout which you can kind of tell from
what I'm hopefully you can see this I
feel like a weather broadcaster like or
something um there's an amazing view and
when I first started dating an
ex-boyfriend of mine we drove up there
it was like our first kiss and um we
watched the sunrise together and I
actually wrote a song about this night
called Ferrari drive that like never saw
the light of day but we watched the
sunrise there and I think that might be
one of the only times I've ever stayed
up and watched the sunrise I've never
pulled an all nighter in my life isn't
that crazy ever I was always like the
first kid to sleep at a sleepover if
everyone was sleeping in the basement
together and it was like a big sumber
party whoever's house it was I was like
I'm sleeping in your bedroom you all
have fun down here so that was me so I
never really watched watched a sunrise
except for this one
night the top of my bucket list I've
always said this as my answer so I will
remain is Bab Bora which now that I'm
saying that I have no idea where it is
in the world whoa okay middle of middle
of the ocean is this where it is I think
so wow okay yeah I I'm really bad with
geography so that is shocking to me it
just seems like a great time I would
love to just also like be in the middle
of the ocean and like not near land or
people which sounds great the place that
takes my breath away is going to be
Victoria Falls so I've actually been
here which is so cool I'm I'm also for
being 24 I have like no idea how to use
an iPhone um I was lucky enough to take
a helicopter ride literally through the
falls with my grandma with my family it
was the most life-changing trip ever and
um they actually have this thing at
Victoria Falls I think it's called like
either the Devil's Pool or the devil's
Jacuzzi or something like that I don't
know but it's on the edge of the
waterfall and basically the only way to
get in it is to jump into the waterfall
and let the current take you essentially
over the edge but then you hit a wall
and you're like oh I'm actually in like
a pool of some kind oh yes oh my God
there's a fun fact the Devil's Pool a
natural infinity pools on the edge of a
sheer drop I did that 15-year-old
Madison was like send me in there the
best show I've ever played in my life
which I'm going to butcher this name yes
oh my gosh okay so this was on my tour
which now was 2 years ago which kind of
breaks my heart and shatters me in ways
I Can't Describe but I played at this
venue I'm not going to try to pronounce
it Le Olympia is my American
pronunciation and this was just the most
life-changing show
ever um my name was on this little sign
big sign and it was just the coolest
show I don't know it was something about
it was so magical and there was just
such like a special energy
in the air this night I don't know maybe
it's a Parisian thing but everyone was
just so amazing and every show is
amazing on my tour so I say this with
caution because I don't want any of my
other fans to be like what about my show
there were so many shows that it's
impossible to pick what the best one is
but Paris might have won on this tour
they might have
won if you're visiting LA and you want
to go to the beach specifically and I'm
sure I'm going to get hate for this
people who live in Malibu are going to
be like no but this beach is already
kind of ruined and it's viral whatever
it's like very much so photographed and
whatever El Matador is an amazing beach
in Malibu it's beautiful there's like
awesome stairs that bring you down to
the water and it's gorgeous there's like
rocks everywhere it almost feels like
you're in Capri it's it's it's an
amazing place um but people who live in
malib get very protective of it and
they're like stop telling everyone about
our beach but if you're there when it's
warm or when it's not it's always warm
who are we kidding okay off the top of
my head we're still going to remain in
la oh that's what it says Ruth Cafe
earth oh my God Earth Cafe yes okay
Earth Cafe on Melrose Avenue in Los
Angeles quintessential like Los La Place
whatever I never go here I'm going to
assume that this person never goes there
as well but I was sitting in this
restaurant minding my business with
honestly a hoodie on like kind of in
hiding a little bit because it's a very
sceny Place whatever and lad approached
me and she tapped me on the shoulder and
was like hey I love your music and I
passed away in that chair um still don't
know if I'm here or there um and yeah it
was a very crazy moment and it very
quickly went from being like Star Struck
to being like I want to be your best
friend so yeah it was really cool and
now I will forever love Earth
Cafe oh my gosh yes okay so I grew up
going here this is Ralph's Ralph's
Italian Isis this exact act one is in
Jericho in Long Island and there are
these little poles which you can maybe
see that are like some of them are you
know yay high some of them are this High
some of them are this High I don't know
what their significance is but growing
up we would always measure ourselves up
to them and I remember the first time I
went to Ralph's and I was the same
height as the tallest beam and I was
like this is crazy but yeah I love this
place I would be shocked if it was shut
down but I'm definitely a little
surprised that it's still like there cuz
it's this little Shack looking thing on
the side of a highway sounds sketchy
what's your favorite flavor I get Blue
Hawaii and vanilla chip chocolate chip
so if you're in Long Island and you want
to try some that's that's my
order what is this place called there's
a place in Long Island that I'm trying
to think of that I don't know the name
of because we don't it doesn't matter we
walk there and go in and I don't even
know if I've ever known the name I'm
going to say New York in general but I
really want to find this exact spot it's
oh my goodness probably called like Mike
and Tony or something like that I don't
know um but we can just say New York in
general New York has the best pizza
argue with the wall I don't care New
York does pizza how Pizza is meant to be
done and bagels by the way so just my
opinion oh
no I've never had McDonald's before in
my whole life and I can't have this I
told myself if I couldn't